Peyton Manning said he hasn't heard from
the New York Jets he was golfing with
Tiger Woods at the Memorial pro-am in
Ohio on Wednesday and Mark Cannizzaro
the New York Post reports that mate
Peyton Manning said that nobody from the
Jets ever contacted me and I'm not sure
I was qualified anyway now look the self
deprecation Peyton you are qualified
let's just dispense with that right away
you are qualified to be the general
manager the New York Jets the question
is what actually was done to gauge his
interest because it never gets to the
point Chris that the Jets directly
contact him if they know he's not
interested and there are easy ways to
take the back channel and find out
whether or not he's in play two phone
calls is all it takes and you know
whether or not Peyton Manning is worth
pursuing
so if Manning's position from the get-go
was no this isn't something I want of
course they're never going to directly
contact him that's not the question the
real question is did anyone reach out to
you quietly discreetly secretly behind
the scenes to find out whether or not
you were interested and I don't know
whether or not that happened all I know
is the league was buzzing that the Jets
wanted Peyton Manning what that
ultimately became from that point I
don't know but clearly it never led to
the point where at least to date they've
called Peyton Manning and said we'd like
you to interview for the job yeah you
know I don't doubt that his name was
maybe thrown around the New York Jets
front office or Chris Judd Christopher
Johnson brought his name up just as far
as tossing around people that might be
you know worthwhile to fill the position
but I don't think you know at least from
the people I've talked to it I know I
know I don't think it ever got serious
and and serious enough to where
yeah they felt like even a phone call to
Peyton Manning you know was even
warranted at that point because I think
they had figured out that he was not
even close to you know accepting any
kind of job like that and I think you
said it Peyton Manning he is qualified
to be a GM and run a football team but I
think what he's saying too in that
comment when he says I don't know if I
am qualified right now and being
self-deprecating which is you know a
nice look for him and the fact is you
know he's not
we know Peyton Manning he's the ultra
prepared and it seems like hey he's just
being Peyton Manning right now playing
golf showing up you know being a
celebrity being a legend that's what he
is he's a legend
and I think when he does do it he's
gonna let everybody know that okay my
focus is here I'm on rosters I'm on
players I'm on team building and that's
what he means by when he's qualified or
ready or not when that time comes yeah
and here's how simple it is
Chris Adam GaSe represented by Jimmy
Sexton of CA a Tom Condon of CAA handled
Peyton Manning's football career all it
takes is gay se to sex and hey Golconda
and find out whether or not Peyton
Manning's ready to do anything and
Sexton calls Condon and Conan calls
Peyton and Conan says yeah he's not
ready and that's it so it you never have
to directly contact him to find out that
he's not interested the Jets have though
directly contacted several other
candidates and the interview process is
heating up champ Kelly from the Bears
will interview in the coming day Scott
fitara from the Seahawks Joe Douglas
from the Eagles those are the three guys
who have been identified as folks who
will sit down an interview for the job
you know not not necessarily a broad
swath of candidates and remember
Christopher Johnson the CEO the team
said he wants a great strategic thinker
it's not necessarily a talent evaluator
and and I don't know who the best
candidate out there is right now but I
really do feel like they have a narrow
universe of people they're gonna look at
because ultimately they want someone who
will be able to work with Adam GaSe who
isn't gonna come through the door with
an agenda of getting his own coach
whether it's this year next year the
year after you want someone who's going
to be joined at the hip with gase and
they're gonna move forward and do
everything they can to win and and now
they get serious about that process of
going through the interview yeah and I
think the best thing and you know if
you're the Jets fan or you know anybody
rooting for the Jets out there they got
the pick of the litter you know hey this
is these are guys that these are the hot
commodities a year before they're gonna
be the hot commodities so you know
everyone who wanted to bag on the Jets
for the bad timing of the Mack Agnon
fire here we go the Jets have the pick
of the litter out of all the people that
want to be GM's for the 2020 season here
they can slowly vet them and figure it
out the way they want to do so hmm maybe
it wasn't that dumb after all to not
have to compete to talk about this the
GM search but either way these are three
guys that I hear about in the
I fell constantly they are towards the
top of the list as far as
cream-of-the-crop is concerned guys to
be future GM's I know I've talked about
champ Kelly Mike I'm a huge champ Kelly
fan from the Chicago Bears I was with
him in Denver Broncos I've had a lot of
long football conversations with him
over the years I've always liked you
know his eye for talent team-building
Joe Douglas certainly has an impressive
resume when you talk about Baltimore
Ravens being there his year with the
Chicago Bears the draft they had and
then helping build the Philadelphia
Eagles to what they are now that's a
pretty strong resume there in itself and
I've heard a lot about Scott fitara but
I just don't know anything personally
about the guy so either way it looks
good for the Jets and it sounds like
they're gonna get a guy that's extremely
qualified for the position but it's not
gonna be the best qualified person in a
vacuum it's going to be I believe the
best qualified person who will work with
Jace who will accept cases the coach
because if you just get the best person
for the job without regard to that
interview or that to that relationship
with Jace you're going to potentially
have even more dysfunction because that
GM is going to want his own coach
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports